Millions of Americans live in distressed communities, where poverty rates are high and levels of education and workforce participation are low.
These areas face many challenges but a big one is their lack of access to capital.
These communities have hopes and dreams, but no one is investing in them.
The new Opportunity Zone program can help. It had governors designate 25% of their low income census tracts to be "opportunity zones"
— more than 8,700 nationwide — and it gave investors tax incentives to funnel capital into revitalization projects there.
These projects can serve a variety of needs, from housing to business investments.
But one of the biggest opportunities is to strengthen the backbone of many of these communities:
education and workforce institutions.
Opportunity zone funds can finance new child care facilities, fund facilities for quality charter schools, or invest in overlooked entrepreneurs.
This program is the largest community -development initiative in a generation, but its success isn't guaranteed.
Community leaders, policymakers, and philanthropies will have to work together to make these investments pay off for their communities
Have you heard about any opportunity zone projects in your neighborhood?
Let us know in our poll, and also let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
Seconds, and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.